[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what are you so worried about saying
oh loud scared they're getting close are
they getting close to the safe now
confiding in silence whispering with all
that violence raging through your brain
always raging all the same
you're breaking out i'm breaking
[Music]
since i can't remember when but you know
nowhere to be found left me here on the
ground i was afraid of your heart i was
afraid of mine it's not supposed to be
easy love
a candle stove flippers in the dark
[Music]
yeah still
fall apart
[Music]
friday
whispers in the dark
[Music]
what are you so worried about for crying
i don't thought i was scared i'm getting
close
am i getting under your skin now
confiding in the silence an orchestra of
tiny violence we're playing all insane
at the funeral in your brain
[Music]
you are dreaming in my nightmares i'm
dreaming in yours i've been looking for
my friend since i can't remember when
but you're nowhere to be found left me
here on the ground i was afraid of your
heart i was afraid of mine it's not
supposed to be easy long i
[Music]
i was afraid of your heart i was afraid
of mine it's not supposed to be easy
love
i can't post those flickers in the dark
i was scared of how i felt i was scared
of what it meant penis
yeah i still
fall apart
friday
whispers in the dark
[Music]
yeah still
[Music]
you